[Music]
hi everyone thanks for taking the time
to watch this video and I just want to
say thank you to everyone who's checked
out the channel over the last year I
can't believe that I finally hit 10,000
subscribers I think I started off with
500 at the start of 2018 so it's a it's
a crazy thing and I just want to thank
everyone who is checked out a video left
a comment cuz that really helps to build
the community light shed I know there's
people being there since day one sharing
my stuff and I just really want to say
thank you because you guys have made it
a really good year for me and so to give
something back I've decided that I'm
gonna give away my favorite film of the
air which is hereditary on blu-ray to a
lucky person who leaves a comment below
basically all you need to do is leave
your top 5 films of 2018 in the comments
below and a month from this video going
up I'll pick a winner and get in touch
with you and then ship a brand new copy
of hereditary to you for free you don't
have to do anything just make sure you
like comment subscribe and everything so
huge thank you for everyone who's helped
to build this channel and I do really
appreciate it and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]